es la primera vez desde 2003 que las
primeras vidas de vino de esta propiedad
se podan a mediados de agosto el año
pasado la vendimia comenzó el 15 de
septiembre para el viticultor de misas
tel xosé el calor extremo y la sequía de
este verano tienen un lado positivo han
creado una uva prometedora aunque en
menor cantidad
son las uvas son pequeñas pero tienen
una piel muy gruesa esto las hace muy
dulces y ayuda a producir muchos taninos
y un bonito color así que será un buen
año pero no habrá mucho
el otro pequeño inconveniente tener que
encontrar vendimiadores antes de lo
habitual aquí hay unos 20 todos de
polonia i'm happy estoy feliz de estar
aquí en francia es realmente hermoso
aquí así que aprecio eso a cambio de su
trabajo se les aloja y alimenta in situ
de manera gratuita empiezan a trabajar a
las seis y media de la mañana con una
pausa para merendar con vino queso y
embutidos alrededor de las nueve y media
a esa hora ya tienen hambre así que es
una oportunidad para descansar y
recargar la energía el rendimiento ha
bajado un 30% en comparación con la
media pero la familia jazztel xosé
reconoce que podría haber sido mucho
peor dado el clima extremo
veíamos que las vidas sufrían y no
podíamos hacer nada más que esperar que
lloviera así que si estábamos muy
preocupados por la sequía en la región
del bollo le la vendimia hecha a mano en
la mayoría de los casos dura varias
semanas y requiere unos 20.000
recolectores